CHERYL: I'm Cheryl,
and I'm super
pleased to be able to
introduce Chris Baty, who
is the founder of National
Novel Writing Month.
Chris is a 15 time NaNoWriMo
winner and the author
of "Ready, Set,
Novel!" and "No Plot?
No Problem!"
CHRIS BATY: Thank you.
Hi, everybody.
Are we working?
Are we live?
OK.
Well, welcome.
Thank you so much
for organizing this.
Last time I was
here at Google, I
ate the most
amazing Indian food.
I think I was here with Anthony.
I still think of
it fondly, so it
is wonderful to be back here.
I've also heard that there are
a lot of National Novel Writing
Month experience
participants at Google.
If you've done National
Novel Writing Month before,
can you raise your hand?
Oh great, OK.
And how many of you
are already planning
on giving it a go this year?
OK, all right,
that's great to know.
So what I want to do
today is just briefly
talk about what
National Novel Writing
Month is for those of you who
are just-- kind of thought
it might be interesting,
or just learning
about it for the first time.
Talk about where
it came from, kind
of the history of writing
a novel in November,
and then get into a few of
these kind of weird lessons
that I have learned about
writing from National Novel
Writing Month.
I think the event
breaks a lot of rules
and conventional wisdom
about the best ways
to go about creative projects,
and I want to talk about those.
And then the main thing I want
to do is leave plenty of time
for discussion.
So those of us at our sailing
into this month of literary
abandoned in November all need
tips and advice and strategy,
and the great thing
about being in a room
full people who've
done it before
is that we all have these kind
of insights and approaches
that are great for sharing.
So I would love to leave time to
have that kind of conversation.
So if anybody has any questions,
we can talk about those,
but really just
think about the tips
that you would have
given yourself,
the things that you wish you
had known the first time you did
National Novel
Writing Month, and we
will share those as a group.
So all right.
So National Novel Writing
Month, in a nutshell,
is based around this really
kind of ridiculous idea
that everybody in the world
should spend November writing
a 50,000 word or longer
novel from scratch.
OK, so that that's not
a super long novel, that
is-- so this for
instance, "No Plot?
No Problem!" this is my book,
and this is about 50,000 words.
So it's a short-ish novel.
Kind of a little bit less than
a "Catcher in the Rye," or so.
So you sign up on our
website nanowrimo.org,
and we have some
amazing stickers here
that have-- will be a
good prompt for the URL.
So before you leave, today
be sure to get a sticker.
These actually will
write your novel for you,
so if you apply
them to your laptop
they will handle the majority
of your word count for you.
So you sign up on
nanowrimo.org, and you
create an author profile.
You can add writing
buddies, so people
that you know that are doing it,
so you keep track of their word
count, they can see
your word count.
You get this really satisfying
stats graph, those of you
who have done National
Novel Writing Month know
the power of this graph, right?
So the goal of 50,000
words gets broken down
into 1667 words per day.
And you update your word count
on the NaNoWriMo website,
you write offline,
update that word count,
and that you get
this progress bar.
You know the progress bar.
Starts to grow, it gets really
satisfying, you get this graph,
and there's a par line, and
you're either over or below it.
And this starts to
kind of take a hold
of your soul in really
interesting ways.
Where you are on
that line determines
how you feel about life,
yourself, everything.
So you also get these
great pep talks,
and one of the things
that we really want to do
is encourage people
to keep going
when the going gets tough.
So we recruit a great
group of authors.
We've had pep talks from Neil
Gaiman, Philip Pullman, Dave
Eggers, Sue Grafton, of course
Aimee Bender, Nick Hornby.
Just all these
great authors that
send out these messages that
tend to hit your inbox just
when you are about to die.
And these things get
you back to the keyboard
and get you writing again.
Another nice thing is that
we have local regions,
so Google has a NaNoWriMo group.
How many of you are in the
NaNoWriMo group here at Google?
OK, great.
So also, there are local
groups in the South Bay
and in the peninsula where
there are write-ins most nights
of the week in November.
So if you want to, you
can go to Starbucks.
Go to a coffee shop, meet up
with other people who are also
doing this, and write with them.
And you can find
that schedule when
you sign up on the
NaNoWriMo website.
So when the month starts, you
just really start writing.
You keep going, and at
the end of the month,
if you have written 50,000 words
or more, you take your website,
and you paste it into
this browser window where
it is counted by our word
counting robots, right?
They're robots.
Jeff-- we have a representative.
Are they cyborgs?
JEFF:They are robots.
CHRIS BATY: Robots, sorry.
Robots always get confused.
No human characteristics
whatsoever.
So the words are counted,
and then immediately deleted.
So I'm going to repeat
that, for those of you who
are new to National
Novel Writing Month.
So you spent all of November
toiling away on this book.
You give up contact with
family members, friends,
basic personal hygiene, all in
the quest of writing this epic
novel, which you
upload to our website,
and it is thrown away without a
human being ever looking at it.
It gets better.
So the prize that you get for
winning National Novel Writing
Month is this golden PDF
of a winner's certificate
that you have to download
yourself and write
your own name on with a pen.
So this is kind of a
curious writing contest,
and it came out of this very
curious time in my life.
So the very first national
novel Writing Month was in 1999,
and I was living in
Oakland, California.
And I think I was just kind
of hungry for some challenge.
I felt like I was like
five years out of college,
and things just nothing
was feeling exciting.
I just was like-- I felt like
I just hadn't done enough.
And I wanted to just
tackle something,
and I had always loved books.
Always revered authors.
And as much as I
loved reading them,
I really never imagined
that I could write one,
because I just was
like, oh novels
like those are
written by authors,
and an author has a
different kind of brain
than the rest of us.
But this idea of writing
a book in a month
had some appeal, where I was
like, OK whatever happens,
it will be over in 30 days.
And that seemed
appealing, right?
So I sent out an email to all
my friends, and I was like,
who wants to write a 50,000
word novel in a month with me?
And I was so surprised that
20 of my friends were like,
Yeah let's do this!
I mean, none of us knew
what we were doing, right?
The last time I think a
lot of had written fiction
was in ninth grade
English class,
so we came up with
this strategy.
And the strategy was that we
were going to write together.
And again this was like
a decision was made out
of fear and
desperation, where like,
if we're going to go down,
we're going to go down together.
So we started getting together
at coffee shops after work.
So week one starts,
and we're there
and we're actually--
so in 1999, this
was not a super common site.
Now it's like laptops
are everywhere,
but those of you who
were bringing laptops
into the coffee shops
in 1999, you were weird.
And we were weird, and
people would call us
the Laptop People
when we would show up.
We would get together in these
coffee shops in Berkeley,
and we would sit.
We would fill up
a booth, and we'd
have the backs of
our laptops touching.
And we would be almost like
this freak show exhibit
where people would always
come over just to look at us.
And then be like, are you
guys playing "Battleship"?
That was the only
reference we'd get.
Or it was, so we're getting
together, we're writing,
there's a lot of
smack talk, it's fun.
And our books go off the
rails immediately, right?
It is not turning out into
the dream of the novel,
where we kind of lose
momentum, we lose focus.
but we stick it
out, because nobody
wanted to be the person
that did not show up
for that writing session, right?
You did not want to be the
coward that didn't make it.
So we kept coming, we kept
making our work counts,
and week two comes and goes,
and then around week three,
this really interesting thing
started happening, which
is that these books that
we had started completely
unencumbered with things
like plots, or characters,
or competent storytelling
ability of any kind whatsoever,
started to come alive.
And those of you who have
written novels kind of
know that moment when
the electricity starts
flowing through some writing
project for the first time.
It feels incredible.
And I think, for us, we had
heard about that moment.
We would listen to
these interviews
with our favorite authors
on "Fresh Air," or the BBC,
and there was always that
moment in the interview,
and they would say, In
your latest masterwork,
your protagonist meets
an untimely demise
at beak of an angry penguin.
And the author says, Yeah.
And then the interviewer
always says this thing
that I never fully understood.
He always says, It was so true.
And the author says,
Thank you, thank you.
And he says, But
I have to ask you,
how did you pick a penguin?
And there's this
great-- the author
kind of rises up to
full authorial majesty,
and says, Oh, I
didn't pick a penguin.
The penguin picked to me.
And I'd be like, authors!
They're amazing!
How do they do this?
And what I discovered that
first National Novel Writing
Month was that, if you
start writing a novel,
and you keep writing a novel,
those penguins just come.
OK?
They come for everybody.
You do not need to have
a degree in writing,
you do not need to know
what your story is about.
There's just something
about this process
of starting a
project and seeing it
through that unlocks these kind
of amazing parts of ourselves
that we didn't know were there.
So it's 1999, we're
heading into week four.
This penguin-tastic
lifestyle is happening,
and all of us that were writing
together in this coffee shop
ended up crossing the
50,000 word finish line.
And you know the books that
we wrote were not good books.
In industry parlance, I think
they would be called bad books.
They were-- we wrote bad
novels, but they were promising.
And I think having started
the month with nothing
and ended it with a reasonably
unhorrible first draft
of a novel, I think, to us,
was kind of this revelation.
Because that was when
we realize that novels
aren't written by novelists.
Novels are written by
everyday people like us
that give ourselves the
time, the permission,
and encouragement
to write novels.
And nothing was the same after
that, because I think all of us
came out of this
experience thinking,
if there was a reasonably
unhorrible book in us
that we didn't know
was there, what else
might be in there
that we know about?
So that was the first
National Novel Writing Month,
and I was like, great
let's bring this back.
I'm going to put up a website.
So the first year's website
was built with an amazing web
development tool
called Microsoft Word.
Have you guys heard of this?
Amazing.
You can do incredible things.
I built a website
using Microsoft Word.
I think it had two links.
I think one of
those links worked.
So the next year, we put
up an actual website.
A web developer friend
of mine built it.
It was nice.
We jumped from 21
people to 140 people,
and I was just like, oh my god.
It's like, we had clearly peak.
This was incredible.
There are literally
140 human beings
doing National
Novel Writing Month.
And the next year, it went
from 140 to 5,000 people.
So this was amazing, and
this is pre-social media.
So this is all word of
mouth people either writing
about this on their blogs or
emailing links to each other.
And, because I was expecting
a maybe like 180 people
to show up the third
year, I did not
have an automated sign-up
or registration process.
Yeah, I'm seeing some
wincing in the crowd.
Yeah, so imagine this.
You are running a website
where you have brilliantly
set up a registration
system where people email
you their name and
their hometown,
you then hand alphabetized
that in an HTML page.
You then send them a
personal welcome email
letting them know that they
have been officially registered.
And then you personally
send them separate email
inviting them to join
the Yahoo club that we're
using as a message
board at the time.
So 5,000 people, getting
those people registered
took us about two weeks of
around the clock working.
And that same group of
people that had been there
for the penguin-filled
extravaganza
thankfully showed up again
with a lot of Red Bull,
and we would have these kind
of all night NaNoWriMo sign-up
processing parties.
But we ended up kind of
getting everybody registered,
and that was great.
And I think that something
really interesting
happened, which is
I think the name
National Novel Writing
Month, that third year
when, again, there are
time people they don't know
that this event is run by
this group of over caffeinated
idiots that don't have any
idea what they're doing,
and they see this name, right?
This name is amazing,
and the name sort
of an inside joke that first
year where it was like there
are 21 of us all living in
the San Francisco Bay Area.
We do not know how
to write novels,
we shall call it National
Novel Writing Month, right?
And people the third year look
at this name, and they're like,
you can't just take a name and
call it like National Something
Something Month, can you?
Like, this must be like a
federally funded literacy
initiative or something.
And then they would see
kind of tips and advice
from the previous year's winners
and they'd be like, all right,
I guess I could do this.
Other people did it,
this seems legit.
So then they did it, and they
had a great month as well,
and wrote a book that
they wouldn't have written
otherwise, and so it just kind
of kept snowballing from there.
So the next year, we went
from 5,000 to 14,000, 14,000
to 24,000.
So last year was our 15th
National Novel Writing Month.
We were very honored to have
the National Novel Writing Month
staff here.
How many people did we have?
JEFF: We had 310
on the main site.
CHRIS BATY: 310,000 adults.
JEFF: Yeah, and then about
closing in at 450,000 total.
CHRIS BATY: OK, so almost a
half a million participants.
We have volunteer run chapters
in 500 cities and towns
around the world.
So wherever you
are in the world,
there's a chance that there is
a local group of National Novel
Writing of participants
that you can go and write
with in November.
We have a Young
Writers program, it's
a free complete novel in a
month extravaganza for kids.
We provide common core mapped
curriculum, free workbooks,
we've got these
amazing progress charts
that we send out for
free to classrooms.
So if you are classroom that is
teaching National Novel Writing
Month, you get to put this up.
The kids put their names, they
set their word count goal.
We do not make second graders
write 50,000 word novels.
They can choose their
word count goal,
and then the amazing
secret about this
is that there are
stickers and buttons.
Those of you who've
been around children
know they will do anything
for stickers and buttons.
So this has been
amazing, where we now
have kids in all
these grades that
are sitting down and writing
their first books in November.
And the great thing about
having a kid or a teen
write their first
book at that age
is that it forever
changes their relationship
to books and writing, right?
And nothing about
writing is scary again.
When you've written
your first novel
as a nine-year-old, right, yeah,
no essay, no college entrance,
none of this is scary.
And it's really just
this wonderful experience
to see that same joy and
understanding that hit me
that first year
start to roll out
in waves across
these classrooms.
So that's been great.
Along the way, we've also
had some really unexpected
literary successes.
So people that wrote the
first draft of their novel
in National Novel
Writing Month that
have gone on to publish it.
So I brought a few of them.
I think it's probably two of
the biggest known that we have.
"The Night Circus" by
Aaron Morgenstern is one.
Another recent one
is by Hugh Howey,
this book "WOOL."
"Cinder" is another one,
and then this is probably the
most famous National Novel
Writing Month manuscript, is
"Water for Elephants," which
was made into a big
Hollywood movie with Reese
Witherspoon a couple years ago.
And so we've had I think, what?
Eight, 10 New York Times
bestsellers, or something?
We've also had hundreds
of traditionally published
manuscripts.
Anthony Francis
right here is one
of our widely published
NaNoWriMo writers.
How many books do you
have out now, Anthony?
ANTHONY FRANCIS: I have
two novels published,
and I am editing the third
one for a release date
early next year.
And the publisher
already has book four,
which is also hopefully going
to come out early next year.
CHRIS BATY: That's great.
That's great.
So we take credit
for all of this.
We-- yeah, we did this.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHRIS BATY: Right.
And the kind of
amazing thing, too,
is just seeing this social
aspect of transforming novel
writing from this kind
of more isolated activity
and making it a group thing
has really also created
these communities that live
on throughout the year.
So people from Melbourne
to Singapore to Stockholm
get together and continue to
work and revise their books
after this initial big push.
And that's been
wonderful as well.
So I have continued to tackle
it every year since 1999,
and not ever a year has been
like as crazy and eye opening.
I think the first time you do
National Novel Writing Month is
a really sweet,
exceptional time.
And there are, I
would say, probably
of the 15 first drafts
that I've written,
I have not looked at
half of them again.
They're just there
on my hard drive,
but I have learned
something about writing
from every single one of them.
I would not trade any
of them for the world.
And this is kind of what
I want to talk about now,
or some of the things I've
learned that I did not
expect to learn about
writing and novel
writing from National
Novel Writing Month.
But I want to start just by
asking, those of you do write,
what is getting
in the way of you
being a more productive writer?
Anybody?
FEAUDIENCE:Not enough time.
CHRIS BATY: Not
having enough time.
Great.
Yeah, a lack of time.
We're super busy, right?
Yeah.
Other?
AUDIENCE: Kids?
CHRIS BATY: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Kids.
CHRIS BATY: Kids, yeah.
Kids, exactly.
Kids strangely are not
all about giving us
the space we need
to write our novels.
What are some other ones.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Self-consciousness
CHRIS BATY: What's that?
CHRIS BATY: Self righteousness?
AUDIENCE: Self-consciousness.
CHRIS BATY: Self-consciousness!
Yeah.
I was like, I love it,
a self-righteous writer
who is just like I'm just
to self-righteous to write.
Self-consciousness
is great, and that's
something I struggle
with, where you
have that sense of is this
really the best I can do?
Do I belong here?
These are great.
What are some other ones?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHRIS BATY: You have what?
CHRIS BATY: You just
sit down, And you
don't know how to start.
Yeah, not knowing what to say.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Lack of
technical skills?
CHRIS BATY: Yeah.
Feeling like, OK,
these are words,
but they're not great words.
This is not-- the
craft of writing
is not present in what's going
on at my computer right now.
What are some other ones?
Yeah?
FEAUDIENCE: Not knowing
what to write about?
CHRIS BATY: Yeah,
the ideas, right?
What is worth
writing about, right?
We read these amazing novels,
and we're just sort of like,
oh, they had such a
brilliant, beautiful idea.
This all kind of-- the plots
and subplots come together, OK.
So these are great and I
so relate to all of these.
And I'm probably going to touch
on all of these in this things
that National Novel Writing
Month kind of helps with.
So the number one
thing that I think
is really great
about NaNoWriMo is
that it lowers your
expectations for your writing.
So because we're into books,
because we're into reading,
we have read a lot of really
wonderful pieces of literature.
And when we set out to
write our own books,
unfortunately, we
make the mistake
of thinking that our novel
should sort of start out
in that ballpark.
And when our writing strays
from that, and for most of us,
it strays from that like around
like the second word, right,
third word maybe--
sometimes you're on a roll
and you get to the end
of that first sentence,
and feel like I was pretty good.
But you said the
second sentence,
and it's like, this is not good.
And I think that
the problem is when
we hit that, we feel like
there's something wrong.
We take this feedback is either
the idea isn't good enough,
or we aren't good enough.
And we abandon the project.
And this happens hundreds
of thousands of times
across writers.
This is endemic.
This outrageously
high expectations
for what's going to
come out is this burden
that writers carry with
us into every project
that we embark on.
So in National
Novel Writing Month,
the great thing is that output
is really all that matters.
If you write 1667
words that day,
and they are the worst words
that have ever been written,
that's great.
You move on.
And I think that's
what you're doing
is giving yourself permission
to write this deeply
imperfect, beautifully
flawed book.
And this is such
a powerful place
to write from, because every
first draft, no matter how
much time you give yourself
to write it, will be flawed.
It's going to be thrillingly
well written in places.
There will be these subplots
that materialize out
of nowhere, these characters
that rise up and take the story
and run with it.
There will be things that
you write that you do not
remember writing in
National Novel Writing Month
that you will reread in
December and be like,
oh you think they've
got Pulitzer prizes
for novel excerpts?
I would be a shoe-in for this.
But the book also is just
going to suck in places.
The plot is going to
wither, the characters
are going to bore
you, and the dialogue
that you write in your
month long novel-- I'm
seeing some heads nodding
here-- your NaNoWriMo dialogue
is going to feel, at times, like
a remedial language lab tape.
And I brought some of
my actual dialogue,
this is from a very early
NaNoWriMo manuscript,
just to give you a sense
of what is in store for you
and to commiserate
with those of you who
have written this before.
OK, here we go.
This is two characters.
We've got Eric and Dan,
and Dan speaks first.
And he says, "Oh, hello, Eric.
The weather's nice today."
And then the response, "Yep.
I agree, Dan.
The sun is warm.
August is my favorite month."
So when you write
dialogue like this,
and you will write
you really have one
of two choices, OK?
The first is that you can assume
that familiar fetal position
underneath your desk,
and you can just kind of
wait for the crying to stop.
Or the second is
that you can get up,
and you can pat
yourself on the back
for having moved, whatever, 19
words closer to your day's word
count goal.
And if you are a Jedi
master, which I am,
you can make it so Dan did not
hear Eric's original greeting,
forcing him to repeat it, thus
netting you nine more words.
And you can do all
of this knowing
that the books that
inspired you to write,
the books that you
love, the books that
helped you see the world
in a new way, all of them
had their version of Eric's
and Dan's in the first draft,
right?
There's a very good
reason they do not
publish the first
draft of a novel
alongside the
final draft, right?
A novel is just
way too complicated
to nail on the first go around.
And the really
powerful thing to do
is embrace this
warts-and-all perspective.
Get that beginning,
get that middle,
and get that end down on
paper, and at that point,
you really know what
the book is about,
and you can go back
in at that point
and start working on that
sentence level polishing.
You can shine that
dialogue, do all of that
once you know what the story
is, and you will save yourself
so much time in the
revision process.
There's this great saying
that you can revise a bad book
into a great book, but you
can't revise a blank page
into anything but a blank page.
And I really feel like
that one of the things
the National Novel
Writing Month does.
It helps you get over
that fear the blank page
and helps you get
words down on paper.
So that's the first thing
National Novel Writing
Month lowers your expectations.
It's a good thing.
The second is that writing so
much so quickly in this very
strange way actually
ends up improving
the quality of your writing.
And this makes no
sense whatsoever,
but it gets into this
interesting world
of writerly momentum.
So there is this writing coach,
you might have heard of him.
His name was Isaac Newton.
Excellent writer.
So in 1687, he
accidentally wrote
this amazing book for writers
called the "Mathematical
Principles of
Natural Philosophy."
He thought it was about physics.
He was wrong.
This is actually
about novel writing,
and he knocks it right out
of the park, like the "Bird
by Bird" of its time.
It's amazing.
He was the writing
down your bones,
and this is what he said.
That first law of
motion, summarized here,
objects in motion tend to
stay in motion, objects
at rest of the stay rest, right?
And we know that
from our own writing
experiences that it is very easy
to become an object at rest.
So I have spent a
lot of time looking
at successful
writers, writers who
are able to produce a
lot, write great books,
and one thing that I think
that they do exceptionally well
is harness the
power of momentum.
And this means that they're
not necessarily really writing
quickly, but they are
writing consistently.
And the great thing about
National Novel Writing Month
is that you have no
choice but to become
this literary object in motion.
You have no choice but
to become this kind
of high velocity,
momentum-powered writer.
And we had this great
pep talk by a YA author
named Rainbow Rowell that
I wanted to read from.
This is her latest book,
it's called "Fan Girl."
And this was a National Novel
Writing Month manuscript,
and so she was writing about
her National Novel Writing Month
experience, and she says, quote
"Normally, I start each writing
session by rewriting whatever
I wrote in my last session.
With my NaNoWriMo
project, I picked up
wherever I'd left off and kept
moving and never looked back.
And what I noticed
right away was
how easy it was
for me to pick up.
During NaNoWriMo, I never
left the world of the book
long enough to lose momentum.
I stayed immersed in the
story all month long,
and that made everything comes
so much smoother than usual.
I got a much quicker grasp
on the main characters
and their voices, and the
plot lines shot forward."
I think when you write
this novel in 30 days,
you don't have time to
second guess everything
that you're writing.
That sense of
self-consciousness is not there,
because there just
isn't room for it.
And as a result, you're
writing becomes looser,
you give yourself
permission in space
to try new things with your
writing, you experiment.
You are building
without tearing down,
you're following tangents
just to see where they lead,
and as a result, you
end up connecting
with these characters in a way
that you wouldn't otherwise.
If you approach writing the
way in the off season I do,
which is kind of parachuting
in and being like,
oh, god, this is such a mess.
I'm going to-- I'm going to
watch one episode of "Game
of Thrones," and then I'm
going to get right back to it,
you know?
And then two months goes by, and
you kind of parachute in again,
you're just like, oh,
god, this is really bad.
And I feel like there is
this incredible power that
comes from being connected
to the story every single day
for a month.
You're getting things
done a level you never
would otherwise.
And the writing
actually does end up
soaring just because you're
in the guts of this thing.
And that's why this
strange rule that when
you write for quantity
instead of quality,
you end up getting both.
So that's the second thing
that I think it actually
does help you write
better in some ways.
And the third one
is the simplest,
which is that it helps you
make time for your writing.
So one of things that somebody
had said, busy being busy,
work, kids, all this stuff.
The truth is we spend so
much of our time taking care
of other people's needs
that may be our family,
might be friends, it
might be work projects
that we need to turn in, right?
That's what we're dedicated
to, and we kind of
have to because either we're
responsible to those people,
and nobody else is going
to be able to do that,
or we're getting paid
to do that thing,
we can't just not show up.
I think, as a result, though
these things like writing,
or art, or music,
these things actually
that are incredibly
sustaining to us
as adults end up forever
getting pushed down
to the very bottom
of our to do lists,
where they will
remain indefinitely.
The nice thing about NaNoWriMo
was that, for 30 days,
we agree hell or
high water, we are
going to orient our lives around
our art rather than vice versa,
and I want to tell you
why this is so important.
You came to this talk
today, you're in this room,
you're in the
narrow club, you're
thinking about doing
NaNoWriMo, you're definitely
doing NaNoWriMo, whatever
it is, you're doing it
because this idea of
creativity and writing
is interesting or
important to you.
And our time on this
planet is really short,
and every year
that we are alive,
a new book becomes
possible, right?
We have this new
understanding in the world.
We're surrounded by this new
cast of characters, right?
We have all of these
inspirations and influences.
And every year
that we are alive,
a book that we might have
written and did not write
slips away.
And the thing that
I love about knowing
that every year, there's
this challenge of bashing out
this 50,000 word
novel in November
is that it forces us to
capture one of these stories
that only we can write.
And that does great
things for us.
I mean, I know in my
experience, this idea
of being creative and
really immersing myself
one of these projects really
does, it makes me feel happier.
I feel like I have more
time rather than less.
It makes me see life just in a
more interesting, engaged way.
And that's great, and that's
a success on a personal level,
but I think it is
also you doing this,
you making time to do
this, and you prioritizing
this is a favor to
the world, as well.
Because whatever project you
are thinking about working on,
whatever this thing is
that you've been mauling,
there are people
out there that have
been waiting their whole lives
to read that thing, right?
They are waiting for that story.
And I think it's just so
important to remember,
with everything else
going on in our lives,
that your voice is
really important.
Your story really does matter.
And I wish everybody an amazing
and over-caffeinated November
getting the first draft
of that story written.
Thank you guys very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Does anybody have
any questions first,
before we get into kind of
like tips for NaNoWriMo?
The question was, what
sparked me to start NaNoWriMo?
I mean, I think for me--
so I'm an only child,
and books were really like
my siblings growing up.
I read so many books,
and there's nothing
more magical than a book to me.
And so I think when I hit
this point in my life,
that sort of like quarter life
crisis point where I was like,
I have nothing meaningful
in my life, you know?
I think books were
natural go-to where
it's like I want
to try that thing.
And I think that, more
than anything else,
is just that sense
of reverence or magic
that I felt about books is what
inspired me to give it a shot.
AUDIENCE: How many is this now?
Because this is the first
year I've heard of it.
CHRIS BATY: Yeah, how
many times has National--
this will be the 15th annual,
the 16th National Novel Writing
Month.
It's been happening is 1999.
Yeah.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Why November?
CHRIS BATY: Yeah, so
that's a great question.
Why November?
So we started it in July.
That was the first
year, which is
an amazing month for
students and teachers, right?
But for everybody else, it tends
to be kind of the only time
you have to be on
vacation, so that
was-- the next year came around,
and people were on vacation.
And so we kept trying
like subsequent months.
In August was no good, September
nope, October, and then we
settled on November.
So it's just pure
vacation happenstance.
Which NaNoWriMo project
have I been most proud of?
I really-- I would say of them,
maybe three or four I've really
just loved and felt
like, oh my god.
This could be a real book.
And I've been working on one
now that I started two years ago
that is the heartwarming
tale of two monsters
who find a VHS tape and
set out to the human world
to return it to its owner.
So soon to be an Oprah
Book Club selection.
And I really-- I
feel like that's
the thing is like, whatever
your current project is,
is always the most
kind of exciting one,
so that's one I've
been working on.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHRIS BATY: That's
a great question.
OK.
Why novels?
Why not short stories?
The nice thing about
National Novel Writing Month
is, in fact, we do have people
writing short stories as well.
And you can really--
there are people
that are sort of drafting
on National Novel Writing
Month's deadline and energy
working on Ph.D. dissertations.
They're working on
memoirs, they're
working on short stories.
And it really is
kind of-- there's
a kind of room
for everybody that
wants to do a writing
project underneath that tent.
What do traditional novelists
have to say about this?
So it's been interesting.
At first, National
Novel Writing Month,
nobody really knew about it,
so nobody had an opinion.
And then it's-- it kind of
grew to this thing where more
and more people were doing it,
and probably around year six
or seven, there was enough
critical mass that people
started noticing was there
and making fun of it,
which I was honored by.
Where I was like,
oh, this is great!
So it's been a real mix
where I think at first,
there was this concern that
we were ruining literature
forever.
And
FEAUDIENCE: Single-handedly.
CHRIS BATY: Right,
single-handedly destroying
culture.
I think because we had this
sort of lighthearted approach
to it where we were definitely,
absolutely committed
to the process, but
I think we were also
kind of giving
ourselves space to sort
of laugh about the
ups and downs of it.
But it's been pretty
amazing over the years
as more and more
professional novelists now
use National Novel
Writing Month, they're
under book contract, they need
to turn in 50,000 words more
than anybody.
So we're now having
this really great mix
of professional writers and
first time amateur writers
coming together,
but we still do,
every couple years,
there's some epic story
about how we're like
killing kittens,
and this is the worst thing
that could happen world.
AUDIENCE: NaNoWrongMo.
CHRIS BATY:
NaNoWrongMo, exactly.
Yeah.
But I think it's hard
at a certain point,
it's just kind of hard
to argue with the fact
that this is almost 4
billion words of fiction,
and this is a
meaningful experience
to the people who are doing it.
And a lot of people write
their NaNoWriMo novels
without any intention
of publishing them.
This is not like step one in
a global takeover of "The New
York Times" bestseller list.
This is really just a personal
sense of joy and satisfaction
they get, and
that's all they want
is to either do
it for themselves
or maybe do and share it
with some family members.
So.
Yeah?
Yeah, so the question is how do
you have that balance where you
have this cast of
characters, and it's
like how do you tell the
story in a compelling way
where each of them
get some screen time?
That's such a great
question, and I
feel like, to me, that is
almost a question I think about
and revisions.
So the first revision,
like the first draft to me
is like this anything goes.
There may be just like
two characters that
are hogging the screen time,
and the third very important
character will show
up, have one line,
and then like
mysteriously vanish.
That's like being sent off on
a very important expedition,
and then just like
left field, gone.
And I think that for me,
the most important thing
is like really getting
your story down.
The full arc of it
down, and then seeing
kind of what characters are
needed, and where they are,
and that's a huge and
interesting question, and one
that writers really
struggle with on all drafts.
But I think in particular,
that first draft
of hitting the balance,
it's just-- it's hard.
I would just say,
read books that you
feel like you
really nailed that,
and I've been really getting
into story structure, which
is something that I
never was into before.
They're like story structure
for nerds out there that break.
There's like the hero's
journey, and the 3x structure
versus the 4x structure versus
the 9x structure versus the 49
memes of storytelling.
But I think just also
starting to look a little bit
about the way books but
you love are structured,
and how they deploy
their characters,
has always been useful.
But that's a great
question, a big one.
So the question of dialogue.
It's how do you know
if it's good or bad?
And I would just
say, let it be bad.
And then, you're right,
and then again, I
would say like let that be
on the page, find your story,
and get through the
end, and then come back
and you're so right, that
dialogue in both books
and movies is not realistic.
If it were realistic, it
would bore us to tears,
because most of what we say is
not that interesting, right?
So it's this shaped thing
where somehow, there's
a little bit of conflict
that's happening
in all of these
scenes, but I think
you can go back through
and kind of know what
the goal of each scene is
once you've written it,
and kind of hone the
dialogue towards that.
That's a great question.
So the question was tell
more about the Young Writers
program in schools.
I want to, though,
quickly say the thing
that I would say
about good dialogue,
reading it out loud helps a ton.
So when you're done with it, go
back through and read out loud
to find the pace.
I'm going to turn this question
about the Young Writers
program for him over
to the NaNoWriMo staff.
You guys want to weigh in on--
GRANT:Yeah.
We have about 100,000
kids and teens sign up
for the Young Writers
program website.
And we ship free
classroom materials
to 2,000 classrooms
around the world.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GRANT: We're out.
Yeah, but anyway.
Yeah, so we support
them, and there are also
like free resources on the
website, like you can download
a free workbook, there
are virtual classrooms
on the website for
teachers to use.
And what's great
about NaNoWriMo is
that we have a staff of eight
and a very small budget,
so we can't go in to
all these 2000 schools,
but we give them the
foundation to teach it.
And so they take it,
and they're going
to apply it to their classrooms
with their own style.
And a lot of
teachers-- what I love
is that they'll take September
and October to like think
about writing a novel,
and planning a novel,
and building a community of
writers in their classroom.
They'll write the
novel in November,
and then they'll use
that for revision.
And then later on
we have sponsors
who give free copies
of self-publish books.
So it's amazing to
me because NaNoWriMo
wasn't around when
I was a teenager,
so I wouldn't even
fathom writing a novel.
I didn't do that
until my late '20s.
And I talk to teens who've
written six or seven novels
by the time they graduate from
high school and published them,
so it's a really amazingly
successful program.
CHRIS BATY: Has NaNoWriMo
been replicated anywhere
outside the English
speaking world?
Yeah, I would say-- I
mean, how many languages?
Maybe 30 languages?
People are writing
all over the world
in their native languages.
So if you go to the Icelandic
form of National Novel Writing
Month, there's people
posting in Icelandic.
And we have chapters
in all those places.
So you could go to
Reykjavik, or Moscow, and--
GRANT: 200 different countries.
CHRIS BATY: 200
different countries.
Yeah, so that's a good question.
I think National
Novel Writing Month
is like unrivaled at
helping people turn off
that inner editor and get
that rough draft down, right?
And then the question
is, so this year, we're
probably going to have close
to 40,000 winners, right?
So 40,000 will write
50,000 words or more.
And in the past, we just
didn't really have this.
The staff is a very small staff.
We do year-round programming,
but we didn't really
have much of like-- so, how do
you help people revise that?
Because that process will at
least take a year, probably,
be many years.
And so this is where I think
the National Novel Writing Month
staff has done an amazing
job in the last couple years.
You want to talk about
sort of what happens,
how do we help people,
after November ends,
do something with this?
GRANT: Yeah, is
this working now?
OK.
Yeah, we have this program.
It's a nascent
program that we've
been testing called "I
wrote a novel, now what?"
And so we try to keep
the spirit of NaNoWriMo
but apply it to revision, which
is a little bit different.
And so I think
a-- and it happens
in January and February, and
you basically, after NaNoWriMo,
you sign a pledge that you're
going to revise your novels.
That's the key thing,
accountability.
And we provide
resources on our blog,
we kind of create conversations
in our online forums,
we hold tweet chats with
agents or published authors,
we hold webcasts.
So we try to reach people in
a variety of different ways.
And one thing we're
really trying to build on
is that now I think what makes
NaNoWriMo so special and so
strong is the
community of writers.
We have a fantastic
And so we want to find ways
to keep building on that,
so the people aren't just there
to discuss writing in November,
but to create a year
long conversation.
So we're building various tools
online to make that happen.
CHRIS BATY: Yeah.
And It's so important.
And that's the thing
I would say too,
that if you do National
Novel Writing Month, that's
just like an
incredible adventure.
But it's really the first phase
of this much longer adventure
of continuing to
revise this book
and eventually sharing
it with readers,
which is just so satisfying.
So the question is
you have 50,000 words
is it a good target?
I think that it is good
in that we get complaints
from both sides, where some
people say that's too long,
it's exhausting, you
are writing so much,
and then we have
other people who
say that's not even a novel.
We have people every year that
complain that the word count
graph ends at, what,
half a million words?
500,000 words, it's capped.
And we get complaints
about that.
People that want to be
writing 800,000 words,
there are people who
do their entire 50,000
words in the first 24 hours.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I don't know how.
CHRIS BATY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHRIS BATY: They-- yeah,
they've got like seven arms
and they're just like whaaa.
So I think the nice thing
about-- so ultimately,
so you look at a book like
"Water for Elephants," OK?
So this, I would
say, this is probably
that's probably
100,000 word novel.
So 50,000 words,
unless you're writing
a kind of specific
kind of genre fiction,
you're not going to
stop at 50,000 words
and have your whole arc.
You're going to end
up adding to it.
But I think the nice
thing about 50,000 words
is that you can get
this beginning, middle,
and end within a month, and
then go in and kind of start
expanding from there.
The funny thing about
that 50,000 word goal--
so the book that I
grabbed when I was
like, how long is
this going to be?
This is 1999.
I'm looking at my
bookshelf and I'm like,
I need to find the shortest
novel that is legitimately
a novel.
And so I saw this guy, which was
like, hello, "Brave New World."
And so this is "Brave New
World" by Aldous Huxley,
and so I counted
the words in it,
and then it took
me awhile, somehow,
and this was not
until much afterwards,
that I realized I somehow had
picked up the movie tie-in
edition.
There's like an NBC
miniseries that actually
has a lot of photos in
the middle of Robert
Redford in kind of like onesies.
FEAUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHRIS BATY: Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
So the original
count of 50,000 words
may have been a
little off base, based
on the photographs in
this version of the book,
but I think it's a great
amount in that you can do it
without really-- it
doesn't kill you to do it,
but you really have to
be focused about it.
Yeah, the great question.
So the question is, do you tend
to just write linearly or do
you jump around?
I think it varies by writer.
I tend to write
from the beginning
and through to the
end, but I do find
that if I'm getting
into this middle part,
and the month is kind of
starting to get away from me,
I will skip ahead.
And it's just so much
easier to revise, I think,
when you do you have
all those parts,
and you're just doing an infill.
So I would say
whatever works for you.
Those of you who have
done this before,
what do you guys recommend?
Jumping around?
OK.
GRANT: If you hit a wall,
you got to keep moving.
So that's the way I do it.
CHRIS BATY: Yeah,
Anthony, go ahead.
ANTHONY FRANCIS: Jump around.
So you start with some
kind of inspiration,
but then it's going to make
you think of things that you
will have never thought of.
You're in NaNo, you
can't lose that.
So you have to write it
as soon as you get it.
CHRIS BATY: Yeah.
I would just say, I think
momentum is so important.
And really, whatever it takes
to keep you moving forward
with that story.
It's all about making
decisions, and that's
the hardest thing with
a novel, because you
want to wreck it, right?
You're like, oh this
is so good so far,
I don't want to
make a bad decision
and take it in
this bad direction.
But the truth is,
there are really
no wrong directions
in a first draft.
Just make the decision,
go, you can always
go back and change it.
Where are they now?
OK, so of the original
crew, where are they now?
So people that did it that
first year are still doing it.
Most of them have taken
a couple years off.
They kind of dip back in again.
I would say almost all of
them have won at least three
more times since then.
But again, most people do not
see themselves as writers,
and a couple of
them hate writing.
They're like, I hate this.
And then they're like, yeah
I'm going to do it again.
it just somehow gets in
your blood, you know?
But of those, yeah I
would say they continued
to do National
Novel Writing Month.
None of them have
published a novel, though.
I'm leaning on them and myself.
That is a great question.
So NaNoWriMo is a grassroots
donations funded nonprofit.
And individual donations
are really huge.
Google has been
wonderful contributor
through the matching
gifts program.
We are a registered
501(c)3 charity.
Grant, you want to
talk about the name
they should be looking for?
GRANT: Yeah, so it's
National Novel Writing Month,
we changed our name from
Office of Letters and Light
to officially National
Novel Writing Month now.
Anthony's a donor
right here, and you
can donate on our
website there's
a Donate tab at the top.
And so we run largely
on individual donations.
We're a very unique nonprofit.
We don't rely heavily on
grants, so I think about 55%
of our revenue comes
from individual donors,
and those are people are
just participate in the event
and love it and want
to support writing.
CHRIS BATY: Yeah,
and that money does
go to both the kids and teens
program, and the adult program,
so any donation
helps tremendously.
And continue to keep
this thing running.
Well, OK, so how
many of you are now
on board with this idea
of giving it a shot?
OK.
I like this, all right.
So in the local--
those of you who
have been part of the
Google NaNoWriMo group,
how can people get
involved here Google?
Does anyone want to share?
ANTHONY FRANCIS: The one
I'm familiar with is,
there's a creative
writing fiction
list that people
on that try to do.
Are there others?
CHERYL: There's also a
NaNoWriMo at Google group.
So feel free to join, you can
find this in groups as well.
And we'll probably have
write-ins for this November,
and then band together and
try to hammer this out.
CHRIS BATY: Yeah, and I would
say if you are interested, so
has is also kindly subsidize.
It looks like they bought
a whole table full.
This is my guidebook to
writing a novel in 30 days.
It's got tips and
advice from people
who have done it a
bunch, it's got pep talks
from some of these authors
that have had great success.
It's probably the best book
in the English language.
and it's out there on the table,
so if this sounds interesting,
and you'd like just a
little guidance through it,
this is sort of
like a travel guide
to your month in NaNo Land.
So thank you guys so
much for your attention
and have a great writing time.